الرياض تخطف الاضواء بجوي اورز مواجهه
تاريخيه بين ميسي ورونالدو وسيد الرافدين
يهدون العراقيين فرحه طال انتظارها
واستعراض مبهر بيونسيه في دبي اليكم
الابراز الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
من حدث الابراج جوائز صناع الترفيه
من ابرز مشاهير الفن وصناع المحتوى
والرياضه في العالم والشرق الاوسط وكان من
بين المكرمين من الجبسون اميتاب باتشان
النجمتان حياه الفهد وسعاد عبد الله
الثنائي احمد حلمي ومنى زكي ومحمد منير
اصاله وانغام ونجم اسود الاطلس لاعب كره
قدم المغربي اشرف حكيمي وقد وجه تركي ال
الشيخ رئيس مجلس اداره الهيئه العامه
للترفيه رساله مؤثره في ختام الحفل لنجوم
الدراما السوريه
الفنانين السوريين
واحشني كثير اشكرك اشكركم على تواجدكم
واتمنى اني اشوفكم ان شاء الله في اعمال
اكثر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وشهدت العاصمه السعوديه رياض ايضا الاسبوع
الماضي المواجهه المنتظره بين اصولتي كره
القدم المعصرين ميسي ورونالدو في مباراه
على كاس موسم الرياض بين فريق المشترك
نجوم ناديين النصر والهلال السعوديين
بقياده رونالدو وفريق نادي باريس سان
جيرمان تفوق فيها الاخير خماسيه مقابله
اربعه اهداف وسجلت المباراه ميسي
وكريستيانو الذي اعتبر رجل المباراه
بهدفين وحظي العلاقه الذي وصف بالتاريخ
بين ميسي ورونالدو بتفاعل كبير على منصات
التواصل
ونبقى في اجواء كره القدم والفرحه الكبيره
التي اهداها المنتخب العراقي لمواطنين
بفوزه للمره الرابعه في تاريخه بلقب كاس
الخليج الخامس والعشرين الذي اقيم مؤخرا
بالبصره وذلك بعد مباراه النهائيه وصفت
بالمجنونه سجل فيها الفريقان المتنافسان
خمسه اهداف وفاز فيها اسود الرافدين على
المنتخب العماني بفارق هدفهم في الثواني
الاخيره من الشوط الاضافي الثاني واحياء
حفله ختام البطوله الفنانه العراقيه ماجد
المهندس والفنانه الاماراتيه احلام واحتفل
الاف من المشجعين بانجاز المنتخب العراقي
في ساحه الاحتفالات الكبرى العاصمه
العراقيه بغداد
امين
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
ومما تفاعل معه رواد مواقع التواصل
الاسبوع الماضي العرض المبهر لبرنسيسات في
دبي بمشاركه اوركسترا فردوس النسائيه
وفرقه الرقص مياس اللبنانيه الحائزه على
لقب برنامج مواهب امريكا العام الماضي
ويعتبروا هذا اول عرض مباشر للنجمه
الامريكيه منذ العام 2018 استمر ل 60
دقيقه واقيم بمناسبه افتتاح منتجع اطلانتس
رويال في نخله جميره والذي يتميزه بتصميمه
الضخم واطلالته اضافه الى حديقته المعلقه
والتي تشكل احد اهم معالمها
بس علشان
يدلعها بسبوسه واخيرا تبادل الرواد مواقع
التواصل في العالم العربي مقطعا وصف
بالطريف وغير المتوقع من عرض ازياء داروي
بيتو الفرنسيه لخريف الشتاء 2023 للملابس
الرجاليه رقصت فيه نجمه العرض الفنانه
الاسبانيه روتانيا والعارضون على انغام
بسبوس عاشق بسه وهي احدى الاغنيات الشعبيه
الرائجه في الشرق الاوسط مؤخرا